[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
es wurden katastrophale Fehler gemacht
zum Beispiel der Wolfgang Grams als er
in die Gerichtsmedizin kam da hat man
seine Einschusswunde gereinigt man hat
seine Hände gewaschen also es gab auch
keine Spurenlage was die Fingerabdrücke
anbelangt es gab natürlich eine
politische Auseinandersetzung ein Chaos
innerhalb der Regierung und das ist eben
komplett aus dem Ruder gelaufen und dann
wurde gebacken eben als Synonym
gehandelt als chaos-einsatz wildreporter
Peter hell fast etwas zusammen was ich
eigentlich nur schwer zusammenfassen
lässt die Fehler rund um den Anti
terror-einsatz in Bad Kleinen es gab
viele Einsätze davor und auch noch
einige Ereignisse rund um die
Terrorgruppe RAF danach aber selten war
ein Triumph und ein Debakel der
Sicherheitsbehörden so dicht beieinander
die an diesem 27 juni 1993
ich bin Toni Heyer und ich freue mich
dass ihr auch diese Folge wieder mit
dabei seid bei dieser wirklich
spannenden Geschichte die wir euch in
zwei Teilen erzählen werden und ich bin
Mirko Casimir beim Erzählen hilft uns
heute neben Peter hell auch Frank
Schneider beide haben sich jahrelang mit
den Geschehnissen von Bad Kleinen und
den Versäumnissen befasst die absolut
kürzeste Fassung geht so bei klein war
einer der größten Anti terror-einsätze
diese deutschen gründergeschichte
gegeben hat und zwar damals auf die
dritte Generation der sogenannten RAF
der Rote Armee Fraktion und diese Links
Terroristen waren damals noch in Teilen
untergetaucht und auf der Flucht und die
Polizei hatte dadurch in der
Verfassungsschutz dass man einen V-Mann
an diese kommandebene daran gespielt hat
die Möglichkeit zu wissen wann die sich
wie wo treffen und bei diesem Zugriff
der super generalstoffmäßig vorbereitet
war hat eine Funk Panne gegeben und
durch diese funk-panne ist dieser
einsetzen aus dem Ruder gelaufen am Ende
ist ein Beamter gestorben durch Schüsse
aus der Waffe des Terroristen Grams und
der Terrors wiederum ist auch durch
erwiderte Schüsse getroffen worden ist
ins Gleis gefallen und hat sich dabei
dann mit der Pistole also merkt er kommt
nicht mehr weg selbst gerichtet am
Anfang entstand das Gerüchte sei von den
GSG neumannten regelrecht exekutiert
worden das stimmt aber nicht am Ende
alles aber zu einer Staatskrise geführt
eigentlich ein super gelungener Einsatz
der am Ende dazu geführt hat dass das
Vertrauen Rechtschreibung worden ist
reisen wir also zurück in den Sommer
1993 und das kann mit Verlaub vom Alter
her wohl Mirko von uns beiden besser
1993 befindet sich Deutschland noch
immer ziemlich frisch in der Zeit nach
der Wiedervereinigung also der
Revolution von 1989 und dem feierlichen
Zusammengehen von BRD und DDR vom
November 1990 in der Weltpolitik macht
gerade der nahostfriedensprozess unter
israels Ministerpräsident
rabinschlagzeilen wenn euch das nicht
bekannt vorkommt wir haben dazu eine
Folge gemacht die findet ihr ganz leicht
in diesem Feed wenn ihr einfach nach dem
Titel rabbin tödlicher Frieden sucht
Deutscher Meister ist 1993 der FC Bayern
München immer mal ehrlich also dafür
wäre jetzt aber auch keine Zeitreise
nötig gewesen und in den Charts finden
sich pop-juwelen wie go west von den Pet
Shop Boys
[Musik]
oder Hop auf deliverance von Paul
McCartney
[Musik]
wovon man in diesem Jahr 1993 noch nicht
gehört hat das ist DIE LINKE
Terrororganisation RAF dabei hatte die
sogenannte dritte Generation dieser
Truppe schon kurz nach der
Wiedervereinigung gezeigt dass man mit
ihr noch rechnen musste
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren der
Chef der Deutschen Bank Alfred harhausen
ist heute von Terroristen ermordet
worden er wurde am Morgen in Bad Homburg
Opfer eines Bombenanschlags das
gepanzerte Fahrzeug in dem Herrhausen
von seinem Haus nach Frankfurt fahren
wollte wurde ferngesteuert in die Luft
gesprengt der 59-Jährige Bank hier
hinter der Frau und zwei Kindern es war
kurz nach 8:30 Uhr heute morgen als eine
gewaltige Detonation das Bad Homburger
Kurviertel erschüttete der gepanzerte
Mercedes ist Vorstandssprechers der
Deutschen Bank wurde mehrere Meter durch
die Luft und quer zur Fahrbahn
geschleudert
die Tagesschau vom 30 November 1989
Frank Schneider ordnet diesen Mord für
uns ein also wir sprechen hier von der
sogenannten dritten Generation es begann
mit der Baader meinhof-bande so hieß das
Jahr er hat sie einen wundern zur Roten
Armee Fraktion und da gab es in den Ende
der 70er ganz ganz schlimme taten die
Entführung vom Arbeitgeberpräsident
Schleier damals dann die Entführung der
Landshut durch palästinente Terroristen
in Unterstützung der RAF damals ist die
GSG9 ja dann auch bei ihrem ersten
Einsatz berühmt geworden und wir sind
aber hier jetzt schon in der dritten
Generation da waren es ganz gezielte
Taten also z.B ist der Deutsche Bank
Chef Herrhausen damals durch eine
Autobombe getötet worden mit einer
Lichtschranke wo es auch immer bis heute
noch immer dieses Gefühl gibt war das
wirklich die FFH super perfekt
vorbereitet so also fast
geheimdienstmäßig vorbereitet man weiß
es bis heute nicht genau und das ist
eben diese dritte Generation von der wir
jetzt sprechen die extreme im Untergrund
gelebt hat sehr verdeckt und bis heute
sind ja auch noch welche unterwegs
die Linksterroristen Leben von Anfang an
in ihrer ganz eigenen ziemlich Kranken
Gedankenwelt und schon kurz nach ihren
ersten Taten in den 1970er Jahren sind
sie eigentlich ständig damit beschäftigt
inhaftierte Kameraden frei zu pressen
aber die sogenannte dritte Generation
will alles anders machen der Terror soll
sich wieder nach außen richten und das
möglichst sogar international zum
Beispiel arbeitete die RAF bei
Terroranschlägen mit der französischen
Aktion direkt zusammen im Januar und
Februar 1985 wurden der französische
General René und der industrielle Ernst
Zimmermann ermordet wenig später
übernahm die ERF gemeinsam mit der
Aktion direkt die Verantwortung für den
Anschlag auf die US-Airbase in Frankfurt
dabei wurden im August 1985 zwei
Menschen getötet und 23 verletzt
und auch der Mord an Herrhausen passte
in die Strategie der RAF Entscheider aus
Militär und eben Wirtschaft aus dem Weg
zu räumen
1991 dann der nächste Schlag Peter hell
fasst ihn zusammen und die Rätsel dir
hinterließ einer der spektakulärsten
Morde war eben auch der Anschlag und der
Mord an Detlef Carsten Rohwedder den
damaligen Geschäft der Treuhand der
sowieso im Fokus stand der war Herr über
Hunderte von Milliarden D-Mark damals
die verteilt werden sollten in der DDR
da gab es natürlich ganz große
Befindlichkeiten und er war wohl auch im
Fokus der FF wo wir da lebte in
Düsseldorf mit seiner Familie eine Villa
am Rhein durch trennt mit einer Straße
dahinter oder nehmen wir ein
Schrebergarten etwas tiefer und im April
1991 ist es dann zu dem Mord gekommen so
wie es später rekonstruiert wurde haben
eben die Täter wohl in etwa 70 Meter
Entfernung über die Straße in diesem
Schrebergarten ihm aufgelauert mit einem
Scharfschützengewehr auf einem Stuhl
stehend geschossen ein präzisionsschuss
in die erste Etage worüber da eben mit
einem Telefonanruf gelockt wurde dass er
oben hinkam sie hatten ihn vorher
angerufen er ist oben in seinen
Arbeitszimmer gegangen und dann wurde er
regelrecht exekutiert mit einem
perfekten Schuss in den Rücken und jetzt
kommt das merkwürdige danach kam die
Frau hoch seine Frau in das
Arbeitszimmer und wurde am Arm getroffen
und dann gab es noch einen dritten
Fehlschuss das sollte wohl so aussehen
als ob es Amateure gewesen sind aber der
erste Schuss war von einem
Scharfschützen der war perfekt
ausgeführt was das spannende daran ist
die Spurenlage danach hat festgestellt
dass ein Handtuch was am Tatort liegen
gelassen worden ist wurde ein Haar von
Wolfgang Grams gefunden das konnten die
Ermittler eben abgleichen und so hat man
diesen Mord eben auch der dritten
Generation zu schreiben können es gibt
allerdings berechtigte Zweifel dass sie
es wirklich waren weil im Nachhinein
konnte man feststellen dass eben
teilweise auch
Stasi-Methoden damit eingespielt haben
und dass DDR ehemalige DDR Stasi
Offiziere ein Interesse hatten Rohwedder
aufgrund seiner Tätigkeit bei treuern
weil da ging es um Milliarden zu
beseitigen so ist skrupellos der Mord an
roweder war zu Beginn des Jahres 1992
erklärte der damalige
Bundesjustizminister Kinkel die
Bereitschaft des Staates das Verhältnis
zur RAF zu überdenken der Staat müsse
dort wo es angebracht sei zur Versöhnung
bereit sein in der Folge kam es im April
1992 zu einer Erklärung der RAF in der
sie die Eskalation zurücknimmt das war
eine Sensation die Terroristen stellten
in einem öffentlichen Papier die eigene
Strategie infrage sie kündigten an keine
Morde mehr zu begehen in der Politik
wuchs die Hoffnung dass der links Terror
bald Geschichte sein könnte aber die
Polizei und die Geheimdienste stellten
ihre Arbeit natürlich nicht ein es gab
noch reichlich Verbrechen aufzuklären
und im Zweifel neue verhindern und
tatsächlich gibt es im Frühjahr 1993
einen spektakulären Anschlag am 27 März
um 5 Uhr kommt es in der hessischen
Justizvollzugsanstalt in Weiterstadt bei
Darmstadt zu einer gewaltigen Explosion
200 Kilogramm Sprengstoff detonieren und
zerstören drei Unterkunftsgebäude sowie
den Verwaltungstrakt der neu gebauten
JVA das Gefängnis ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt eines der modernsten in Europa
und soll ausschließlich als
Untersuchungshaftanstalt genutzt werden
die Inbetriebnahme der Einrichtung steht
kurz bevor durch die massiven
Explosionen werden große Teile der
Anlage schwer beschädigt es entsteht ein
Sachschaden von mindestens 80 Millionen
Mark die RF begründet den Anschlag unter
anderem damit das Weiterstadt so
wörtlich auch der zentrale hessische
Abschiebeknast werden sollte
die Terroristen haben nach eigenen
Angaben sehr genau darauf geachtet dass
kein Mensch zu Schaden kommt aber
trotzdem von einem Ende des Terrors kann
überhaupt gar keine Rede sein davon sind
das Bundeskriminalamt und
Generalbundesanwalt von Stahl aber ja
sowieso nicht ausgegangen wo immer sie
können versuchen Sie RAF-Terroristen
ausfindig zu machen und festzunehmen im
Sommer 1993 ist ihre heißeste Spur
Birgit Hogefeld damals 36 Jahre alt sie
war 1984 mit ihrem damaligen
Lebensgefährten Wolfgang Grams in den
RAF Untergrund abgetaucht die Behörden
gehen davon aus dass so gefällt im
August 1985 mit Täterin bei der
Ermordung des US-Soldaten etwas pimental
war auch beim Sprengstoffanschlag auf
die Rhein-Main Erbe ist soll sie
beteiligt gewesen sein
der Clou im Jahr 1993 der Polizei ist es
gelungen einen Agenten an ihrer Seite zu
platzieren einen sogenannten V-Mann
Klaus Steinmetz seit Jahren in der
linken Szene aktiv berichtet dem
Verfassungsschutz seit 1992 regelmäßig
von Treffen mit rf-mitgliedern Frank
Schneider beschreibt uns das man wusste
dass der V-Mann sich mit Birgit Hogefeld
trifft das war die große Kunst des
Verfassungsschutzes
man weiß ich eigentlich ziemlich sicher
dass die beiden sogar über ein
Liebesverhältnis verfügten und die
beiden sich sehr nahe stand und deshalb
wusste man immer wo er ist ist auch die
hohe Feld und die haben sie in einer
Ferienwohnung getroffen sind dort auch
serviert worden und dann hat man
plötzlich gehört wir wollen noch Freunde
treffen und das Wasser Signal für die
Beamten zu sagen Stopp wir warten ab wir
können hier heute wahrscheinlich nicht
nur eine Terroristin festnehmen sondern
mehrere
so sieht es also aus an diesem 27 juni
1993 als die Verfassungsschützer hören
das Steinmetz sich mit Birgit Hogefeld
in Bad Kleinen treffen will entschließt
sich der Generalbundesanwalt Alexander
von Stahl zum Zugriff unter dem
Decknamen Weinlese untersuchen BKA
Verfassungsschutz und Staatsanwaltschaft
wo und wie man wo gefällt festnehmen
kann
Steinmetz und hogefels planen einen
Kurzurlaub in Wismar dort soll der
Zugriff erfolgen der Bahnhof in Bad
Kleinen wird ebenfalls in Betracht
gezogen und wieder verworfen zu
unübersichtlich zu gefährlich für die
Aktion stehen knapp 100 Polizisten
bereit darunter reguläre Beamte aber
auch Spezialisten der GSG 9 sie sollen
hoher gefällt und zum Schein auch V-Mann
Steinmetz auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof in
Wismar aus einem kleinen Bus heraus
überwältigen
über eine Wanze die sie Steinmetz
untergeschoben haben hört der
Einsatzleiter Jürgen Peter aber etwas
sehr Interessantes Birgit Hogefeld
erwähnt dass sie heute noch Freunde
treffen will Sekunden vor dem Zugriff
entscheidet Peter abwarten denn nun
müssen die Einsatzkräfte in Windeseile
einen neuen Ablauf erstellen nach
Monaten der Planung der Zugriff soll nun
doch auf dem Bahnhof in Bad Kleinen
erfolgen Frank Schneider und daraufhin
hat man die wieder observierte verfolgt
bis zu diesem Bahnhof sie waren falsch
auf der Rückreise von Wismar aus der
Ferienwohnung und wollten von Bad
Kleinen weiterfahren wie wusste man
nicht dann haben sich in der
Bahnhofsgaststätte getroffen mit eben
einer weiteren Person das war der zweite
Terrorismus Wolfgang Grams und dann
haben sie gemeinsam die Gaststätte
verlassen auf dem Weg zum
Bahnhofsvorplatz wo dieser Opel stand
der dann auch kontrolliert werden sollte
das bis heute der Verdacht dass er
möglicherweise zwei weitere Terroristen
gesessen haben und auf diesem Weg durch
die Unterführung von der
Bahnhofsgaststätte runter die Oma und
Bahnsteig war runter die Treppe durch
die Unterführung dort ist es dann zu
dieser Panne gekommen eigentlich stand
die GSG9 bereit ein paar Meter weiter
ich gehe davon aus die Touristen ich
meine wir reden hier von der
Heldentruppe aus Mogadischu das waren
die Best ausgebildesten antitarre
Spezialisten in Deutschland die hätten
wahrscheinlich gar nichts gemerkt hätten
die schon am Boden gelegen und durch
diese eine blöde Panne ist dieser ganze
Einsatz verrutscht also eigentlich eine
riesen Erfolg bis zu diesem Moment wo
das Wort wenn hört wurde
also nochmal langsam die Polizei weiß
jetzt dass drei Personen aus der
Bahnhofsgaststätte kommen werden die
gesuchte Terroristin Birgit vogelfeld
der Frau Mann Klaus Steinmetz und als
zufallsfang wo gefällt Terror Komplize
Wolfgang Grams auf dem Vorplatz steht
außerdem ein dubioser Opel von dem man
nicht weiß wer drin sitzt und in dieser
Situation die eigentlich ein Triumph für
die Sicherheitskräfte werden soll
passiert Sie
Frank Schneider ja es war so man muss
jetzt vorstellen wir reden hier von 1993
also wenige Jahre nach der
Wiedervereinigung wir haben einen
Bahnhof in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern klein
der eine Unterführung hat dort
schlechtes Funknetz auch herrscht die
Polizei wusste vor dass möglicherweise
an diesem Bahnhof zum Zugriff kommt auch
die Spezialeinheit der GSG9 und deshalb
hatte man vorher sogar schon Verstärker
dort installiert man wollte eben genau
nicht das Risiko eingehen dass etwas
schief läuft und dann ist aber eben doch
so passiert das damals wurde analog
gefunkt und dann kann es immer so sein
wenn man das Funkgerät ist etwas zu früh
drückt oder zu früh spricht oder zu spät
drückt das Worte verschluckt werden das
Worte nicht wahrgenommen werden und hier
war es so dass der Funkspruch eigentlich
lautete wenn Zugriff erfolgt dann den
Opel auf dem Bahnhofsvorplatz
kontrollieren weil man dachte da könnten
noch weitere Terroristen drin sitzen und
der Funkspruch der ankam bei dem Beamten
war eben ohne wenn Zugriff erfolgt Opel
am Bahnhofsvorplatz kontrollieren und
das war das Problem der dachte der
Zugriff ist bereits erfolgt die
Terroristen sind festgenommen sind
sicher wie man das nennt und es war eben
genau nicht so und der ist aus einer
Deckung gekommen und stand auf einmal
vor den Terroristen und hat sich dann
doch wahrscheinlich unbewusst doch
irgendwie auffällig verhalten jedenfalls
haben die gemerkt da stimmt was nicht
und dann hörte er plötzlich Zugriff
Zugriff Zugriff und dann hat er die
Birgit Ruhe gefällt die damaligen
überwältigen können aber der Wolfgang
Gram ist der andere Terrorist der konnte
eben noch flüchten konnte seine Waffe
ziehen und dann das Feuer eröffnen also
es ging eigentlich nur um dieses eine
Wort wenn weniger Augenblicke später
sind zwei Menschen tot der GSG9 Beamte
Michael nefzeller und der Terrorist
Wolfgang Grams wer hat auf wen
geschossen hat die Polizei den gesuchten
Schwerverbrecher Grams absichtlich
getötet regelrecht hingerichtet sogar
was würde das für die Politik bedeuten
diese Fragen beantworten wir euch im
zweiten Teil und ich hoffe natürlich
dass sie da auch wieder mit dabei sein
werde bis morgen eure Toni und euer
Merkur